the longest running british med drama we
have to review it season 36 what let's
go
[Music]
hey
good reaction
hey by both parties hey what are you
doing don't road rage that's not healthy
abusing fellow road users isn't very
constructive
never grab a moving vehicle that is an
argument fight you will never win
whatever sound effect i just heard from
her grabbing the car door there didn't
sound good also didn't sound super
realistic i'm assuming she's gonna have
like a dislocated shoulder here or
something but it didn't sound real it
sounded too meaty he was like
he must have driven off at some speed to
dislocate his shoulder dislocated
shoulder the most common type of
dislocation is an anterior shoulder
dislocation
hey lily how are you feeling
oh yeah i'm all good i'm ready to rock
and roll in general i don't like keeping
patients in slings like this because it
actually causes uh increased rate of
frozen shoulder where you have decreased
mobility you get less range of motion
thereby having less healing look thank
you for everything i just i really want
to get back to my van yes so x-rays look
okay all right well obviously you can't
drive with that shoulder
i
can't just leave it there and
it's my home yeah yeah it's your home i
get it it's my dad
he's in the back
he's got early onset dimension but you
wouldn't know if you met him he just
forgets a bit sometimes even mild
dementia can become problematic when it
comes to tasks like managing your money
paying bills being susceptible to scams
think about it if you don't have a good
memory somebody can call and say you
didn't pay a certain bill asking you for
personal information you could just give
it up to them and speaking of scams if
you see someone that looks like me or
using a name similar to me giving out
whatsapp phone numbers that's not me
just like the fake accounts on instagram
that's a fake account on youtube record
that bad boy you're going to look for
clive aren't you who's life
lily's at dad look i've just been
calling the police let them deal with it
these are overstressed i'm saving them a
job the ambulances look so different in
the uk than they do in the u.s i've
never seen them that color but i guess
they stand out so it actually makes
sense that they're this color
[Music]
he's not here did she just leave her dad
in the van like i don't understand was
he awake was he alert come on cudigan
walters
and she said mild dementia like mild
dementia shouldn't interfere with
navigation
i think i might need a bit of help yeah
it's quite a nasty cut you got there
let's try and stop it bleeding shall we
what are they gonna do couldn't get up
you got anything in there i can use as a
tourniquet yeah you can do a makeshift
tourniquet but those are never as good
as commercial grade tourniquets those
can actually cut off the circulation and
you also need to make the decision of
how bad the person's bleeding out you
can stop the bleeding with just some
pressure that's a better option having a
tourniquet on especially a serious one
for a long period of time can cause harm
to the limb anything in the air can use
a dressing
well like a nappy maybe how about
calling for help like they're making a
tourniquet but at the same time they're
like so what's up you got diapers what's
the next best thing
did she just apply a pad like this and
hopes it's gonna stop the bleeding in a
high pressure system
no put some pressure on it i thought it
was extremely weird he got on a ride at
a a carnival and there's no one there
look at me ladies no stop it please
can someone help
okay okay all right let's get you back
in come on wait okay clive it's okay
it's okay okay clive look at me look at
me it's faith remember from the
fairground now now look at your arm your
arm is bleeding do you
remember that's not mild dementia
anymore if you're starting to forget
where you are and you start acting this
inappropriately that's already starting
to become moderate to severe also could
point to uh other medical problems it
could even be acute medical problems
like normal pressure hydrocephalus
come on ethan let's get you inside
no i never want to come back here we
need to get you inside get some
treatment you've got a virus
vitals look uh semi-realistic we have a
91 pulse a 96 pulse ox i do not see a
blood pressure on that machine maybe
they didn't check it recently
ethan's got the huntington's gene so
huntington's disease is a progressive
neurologic disorder where essentially
the brain and the neurologic system
starts breaking down over time and it's
a deadly deadly illness i mean like from
the time the disease presents itself you
have like
10 to 30 years before death it's that
quick and there are genetic tests
available for that and it's even
sometimes a highly debated topic of
whether you should be tested for this if
you're not doing it for genetic planning
for future children finding that out
could seriously impact your life for the
good or for the bad so it really depends
on what kind of personality you have
whether or not you want to know
[Music]
oh
that was a serious collision my thing is
if you just crashed into someone have
the courtesy to hit that bad boy in
reverse and pull out to the person who's
not trapped
keep still i know it's scary but try and
keep still
my name's jade what's your name
[Music]
emma
she's really good at keeping this person
calm what have we got
this is emma nash 31 years old driver
involved in an rtc car versus lorry cab
about 40 minutes ago she was executed by
the fire fighters top to toe buggy
hematoma on the side of her head chest
wall bruising from seat belt got a
laceration with arterial bleed on her
leg opposite stable gts is 12. this is
literally not how this should happen
this is a serious trauma she's bleeding
out we should have blood drawn already
we should have tests going she should
actually be fully undressed because you
need to do a visual exam to see where
she's bleeding where the bruising's
happening if you've missed a laceration
somewhere because that delay in
diagnosis could cost her her life okay
you ready to inch bait there should be a
full team here like everyone's too calm
and cool this doesn't seem realistic at
all
what is he even doing okay let's get
laryngoscope et tube and and be back on
standby please
okay those are the right tools for
intubation
i love that it was him opening her jaw
but she actually went
and opened for him what happened here
sorry you can't be in here emma
emma who did this what happened can i
get you to wait outside please this is
why he needs more staff so he's not
doing this alone this is so weird for me
to watch there's literally usually seven
more people in the room drawing labs
controlling the patient's family doing
chest compressions if need be putting in
ivs gathering the patient's belongings
entering data into the system putting
more orders like there's so many things
that need to happen all at the same time
you can't be in here right now she's my
sister also you need to make sure that
you've intubated correctly and it's not
in the patient's stomach
[Music]
i'm a doctor just tell me what happened
okay i'll explain everything outside
oh my god did he intubate into her
stomach no
she's been seriously injured i need to
speak to the neurosurgeons and they'll
they'll decide whether she'll need
surgery
i want to stay with her
can i get you to wait in reception
i promise i'll look after her this is
such an awkward conversation nothing
about this seems genuine or authentic
uh hello yes it's ethan hardy calling
from the ed he's calling for a
neurosurgery consult which like okay
fine you can call that place the order
whatever call who you need to call but
like the fact that he's like not taking
care of the patient right now is a big
problem oh she's been like this
did you check the placement the tubes
and esophagus oh no
that's why you need more people in the
room who is the one bagging the patient
remember he didn't hook her up to a
ventilator he hooked her up to a bag so
someone had to be sitting there
squeezing it and watching her pulse go
up and her oxygen saturation go down
you're here for a monash is that right
you're her sister i am if this is about
emma i'm a fiance she suffered a
significant head injury and she made any
neurosurgery once the surgeons have
assessed her
now her brain was starved of oxygen for
a short while and we won't know yet in
if there's been any permanent damage
what does that mean how did she end up
like that i thought you said this was a
car accident it's too early to tell
and if the neurosurgeons can't offer an
operation we'll need to stabilise her
you didn't say any of this before what
changed
no you intubated patients don't just
lose oxygen something else happens
something he's not telling me that's so
not true patients absolutely do in the
process of intubation go a short time
without oxygen it's not like a patient
stops breathing and you right away are
now inserted into the patient's airway
the fact that this doctor knows that
something's wrong already is weird
obviously they're being sketched that's
part of it but just a whole weird
situation i i intubated her esophagus by
mistake
but you recovered it straight away
you've checked the o2 tracing yeah yeah
i've done that i could have killed her
it's a recognized complication of an
intubation it's true when you're
intubating a patient the risk is that
you intubate their esophagus by accident
that's why you check you could check the
o2 sensor or you could put the little
stethoscope on the lovely chest and see
if the chest is rising not the stomach
another thing you can do is obviously
get a portable chest x-ray for placement
but that is obviously not ideal because
it takes longer gonna introduce me
of course so ethan this is our new
consultant dr nash
stevie please and uh
i know who you are
you're dr hardy right
yes i am that's her daughter or sister
or whatever
[Music]
is she gonna do something bad i don't
know
but i do know you should watch my
favorite med drama reviews here so click
that check it out as always stay happy
and help
[Music]